[Music]
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV
today we're talking with Judge Andrew
Napolitano author of the new book lies
the government told you miss power and
deception in American history judge
thanks for talking pleasure to be with
you Nick whether we're talking about my
book or anything why did you write this
book because the thing that impressed me
the most when I was on the bench as a
judge hearing arguments between the
government and a defendant in a criminal
case or the government and someone who
had been injured by the government in a
civil case was the extent to which the
government would lie and people in the
courtroom members of the jury lawyers
involved in the case would expect the
government to lie you know there are at
least a half dozen Supreme Court
opinions that say the government can lie
tell us what what's one of them well the
context in which the government may lie
is when it's interrogating a potential
defendant the classic modern-day example
is Martha Stewart she's with an FBI
agent there in her lawyer's office the
lawyer says to the FBI agent is my
client a target the FBI agent says no
the FBI agent then says to Martha
Stewart did you buy such and such a
stock on such-and-such a day she says no
they each lied she went to jail for five
months and he got a promotion through
well what is it about the government are
they morally superior to us that they
can lie with impunity
lie with the law behind them and if one
of us would presume to do it to them we
could end up in jail the the government
has institutionalized lying from all men
are created equal
hard for me to to attack that because it
was written by my hero and favorite
president Thomas Jefferson too we don't
torture and about fifteen or sixteen
significant historical lies in between
when I kiddingly told friends I was
writing a book about the government
lying and it was four thousand pages
long many of them said you've got all
the lies in 4,000 pages obviously it's
not four thousand pages it's three
hundred but it shows you how
acculturated we are to the concept of
government laws
let's talk about some of the specific
laws that you run through you say one of
the lies is we don't torture how is that
a lie and what what is destructive not
just about the torture perhaps but the
lie almost all government lying is
destructive because it induces people to
to view the government in a false
environment some lies like LBJ in 1964
I'm the peace candidate or FDR in 1940
your boys will never fight a war on
foreign soil or George Bush in 2004 we
don't torture I'm not spying and they
have weapons of mass destruction those
are the category of lies that induce us
to give power to the government based on
those lies question would we have given
that power to the government had we
known the truth the we don't torture is
particularly offensive a it's it's
incorrect it's a lie and the person who
said it
President Bush must have known that it
was a lie because we now have documents
that we know he saw in which he
authorized torture be it's particularly
horrific because it rejects the notion
that all men are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
if they cover all those - in torture to
torture someone they reject the notion
of an alien some people would say that
well you know we don't torture American
citizens why from your point of view is
does it not matter if we're torturing
non-citizens or this morning the
Washington Post reported that the CIA
announced that it will target Americans
when they're overseas for assassination
so it's obvious that being an American
is no additional protection but as a
matter of constitutional law the
Constitution protects persons it's not
limited to Americans and persons is not
even limited to good persons it protects
Americans it protects aliens it protects
those legally here protects those
illegally here protects those who wish
us well and those who have caused us
harm it makes no distinction whatsoever
this is absolutely consistent the
constitutional protection of persons
with the Lockean and Jeffersonian and
Augustinian view
and to mystic view that our rights come
from God and our gifts into our humanity
and are as much a part of us as the
fingers on the ends of our hand that
would apply to me to you to George W
Bush to Barack Obama to Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed to Richard Speck to Al Capone
to anybody that the government wants to
restrain for any reason do you think
that natural law is gaining ground or is
receding amongst people who are
concerned with the government amongst
people who have come to realize that we
have rights that are integral to our
humanity it's gaining ground amongst
young people it's gaining ground amongst
the Liberty movement it's gaining ground
amongst reasons viewers listeners and
and readers it is gaining ground in the
government it is not the other day at
Fox I asked Congressman Jim Clyburn the
number three ranking Democrat in the
house congressman Clyburn where in the
Constitution as the government
authorized to regulate healthcare and he
said to me judge most of what we do is
not authorized by the Constitution where
is it prohibited to the government to
regulate healthcare he has turned the
night in his own mind turned the notion
of limited government on his head on its
head and believes that the Congress can
do anything it wants unless it's
specifically prohibited in the
Constitution but the concept of natural
law articulated in the Declaration of
Independence codified in the Bill of
Rights is the opposite of that and that
is Congress may only do what the
Constitution authorizes it to do and
there are areas of human behavior where
Congress may not regulate no matter what
the good there may be that could come
from its proposed regulation let's talk
about a place another lie that speaks to
this Congress shall make no law
abridging free speech this is arguably
the most important right it is and what
are the ways in which you know when you
look around the world today or look
around America today we have much more
access to many more materials is
censorship is abridgement of free speech
and issue and in what way look free
speech was just saved by three black
robe judges in this
city earlier this week when the United
States Court of Appeals for the District
of Columbia Circuit ruled that the
Federal Communications Commission cannot
regulate the Internet they really wanted
to make sure that there was the Fairness
Doctrine on the Internet
I mean if anything is the free
marketplace of ideas today it is the
Internet but this goes way back Nick I
mean think about it the same generation
in some instances the same human beings
who wrote Congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of speech also
wrote the Alien and Sedition Acts which
made it a crime to criticize everybody
in the government except the
vice-president because it happened to be
Jefferson at the time congressman
Matthew Lyon of Vermont if anybody is
from New Orleans Chicago or New Jersey
they'll appreciate this story
congressman Lyon from Vermont was
prosecuted for criticizing the president
John Adams for being too involved in the
pomp and circumstance of the office but
the most offending thing he said was and
John Adams had a little problem with his
waistline he referred to the President
as his rotundity here's the New Orleans
Chicago New Jersey angle Lyons was
re-elected to Congress from his jail
cell because people were so outraged at
this prosecution but think of it we
fought a war against a king and a
parliament 3,000 miles away because they
they assaulted speech we became a
country and we began to assault speech
Lincoln locked people up for what they
said Woodrow Wilson locked people up for
what they said FDR locked people up for
what they said George W Bush locked
people up for what they said so what
part of shall make no law does the
Congress not understand who did George
Bush lock up for what he said to
librarians in Bridgeport Connecticut
were served with a self written search
warrant authorized by the Patriot Act
that's where an FBI agent and his or her
boss together write a search warrant
without going to a judge as the Fourth
Amendment requires the FBI agent shows
up at this library the librarian is 86
years old he hands her the search
warrant says don't tell anybody about it
she looks at him and says who the hell
are you
she was he was young enough to be her
grandson she hands the search warrant
to her assistant that was considered
speech telling somebody else that she
had received a self written search
warrant the Patriot Act makes it a crime
to tell anyone that you have received a
self written search warrant you can't
tell your spouse in the bedroom
your lawyer in her office your priest in
the confessional you can't even tell a
judge in a public courtroom under oath
that you received it this 86 year old
librarian told her 75 year old assistant
and the government went after them
[Music]